Привет! В прошлых двух уроках мы собрали конкурентный анализ. Таблица фич, свод, UX паттерны — это вид сверху, общая карта рынка. Сейчас спустимся на уровень ниже. Возьмём одного конкретного конкурента и разберём его экраны. Но не просто в формате «потыкал», «записал впечатление». Мы проведём полноценный экспертный аудит по той же методологии, которую используют UX-специалисты при профессиональной оценке интерфейсов. Какого конкурента выбрать?
Ну, наверное, самого близкого к вашему продукту. Конечно, лишним не будет посмотреть парочку. По конкурентному анализу вы уже знаете, кто для вас самый близкий конкурент. Поэтому в рамках выполнения домашки можете взять именно его.
Методология, которую мы используем, называется «Эвристическая оценка». Её разработал Якоб Нильсон, один из основателей дисциплины юзабилити. Суть в том, что интерфейс проверяется по десяти конкретным принципам. Сейчас мы их посмотрим. Вот эти принципы. Давайте по каждому пройдёмся.
Первый – это состояние системы. Пользователь всегда понимает, что происходит. Есть индикаторы, статусы, подтверждения. Второй – это соответствие реальному миру. То есть интерфейс говорит на языке пользователя, а не разработчикам.
Дальше у нас свобода и контроль. То есть можно отменить действия, вернуться, выйти без потери данных. Далее – консистентность. Одинаковые элементы выглядят и работают одинаково. Дальше – предотвращение ошибок. То есть интерфейс не даёт ошибиться, а не просто сообщает об ошибке постфактум.
Узнавание вместо запоминания. То есть вся нужная информация на экране. Не нужно помнить что-то с прошлых шагов. Гибкость и эффективность. Про то, что должны быть шорткаты для опытных. И какой-то простой путь для новичков.
Далее у нас минимализм. То есть нет лишней информации, которая конкурирует с важной. После помощь с ошибками. Сообщения понятные. Предлагают тебе сразу решение. И самое последнее – это документация.
Если сложно, то есть соответствующие подсказки. Каждый из этих принципов – это конкретный критерий. Когда агент проверяет экран по каждому из них, он не просто придумывает замечания из головы, он проверяет по конкретному чек-листу, по этим самым эвристикам.
Результат получается структурированный и воспроизводимый. Плюс к эвристикам мы используем еще когнитивный подход. О каждом шаге пользовательского сценария есть 4 вопроса.
Поймет ли пользователь, что делать? Заметит ли нужный элемент? Свяжет ли его с целью? И поймет ли, что он продвинулся? Если на каком-то шаге ответ нет – это уже проблема. И каждая проблема получает уровень серьезности. Всего у нас 4 уровня.
Первый – это просто косметика, визуальная шероховатость. Она не мешает пользователю работать с системой. Далее у нас малозначительные проблемы. Они замедляют флоу, но не блокируют его. Тут уже, конечно, стоит присмотреться.
Далее – значительные проблемы. Это серьезное трение, на котором многие могут застрять. И последнее – это вообще катастрофа. То, что мешает пользователю в целом выполнить задачу.
Блокирует его путь полностью. И это, конечно, проблемы с самым высоким приоритетом.
Получается, что вся оценка у нас очень точно структурирована. Это не просто «мне кажется тут что-то не так», это формализированная оценка с приоритетами.
А для аудита агенту, конечно, нужны материалы. Минимум – это скриншоты экранов. В идеале – это скриншоты плюс описание юзерфлоу.
Вот наша агентская среда. Я здесь уже создал папочку «аудит», в ней папку «скриншоты» и сюда закинул вот эти самые скриншоты.
Я взял TimeWeb – это мой основной конкурент именно в рамках вот этого продукта.
И проскринил два пути. Это облачные сервера, сборка этого сервиса, его конфигурация.
И выделенные сервера. Точно так же от начала до конца.
Смотрите, здесь какие у нас есть нюансы. Во-первых, нужно пронумеровать вот эти скриншоты от единички до самого последнего,
чтобы он точно понимал, как вы двигались по этому флоу. Это очень важно.
Далее. Нелишним будет еще проставить название, что происходит на конкретном скриншоте, на каком этапе флоу.
Это также агенту сильно поможет. Я, разумеется, самостоятельно это все не переименовывал.
Я просто закинул агенту, сказал, посмотри бегло, что там происходит и поставь имя этому скриншоту.
Просто, чтобы вручную этого не делать.
И в эту же папку «аудит» можно добавить еще «userflow.mdm», в котором будет описание того, что на каждом экране.
Я этого делать не стал. Но, конечно, с этим результат будет точнее.
И теперь немного об ограничениях. Агент видит статичные экраны. Он не видит анимации, переходы, время загрузки, поведение при скроле и так далее.
И это принципиальное ограничение скриншотного аудита. И профессионального на самом деле тоже.
Полный аудит, конечно, требует живого взаимодействия. Но по скриншотам можно закрыть 70-80% эвристик. Это уже очень немало.
Ну и, конечно, как обычно, для аудита я подготовил директиву, готовая инструкция. Давайте ее посмотрим.
Внутри у нас когнитивный обход, все 10 эвристик и шкала серьезности, по которой нужно будет проблемы распределить.
Также, как обычно, тут есть формат отчета, в каком виде у нас должен быть результат. В общем, все как обычно.
Также обратим внимание, что агент еще и читает бриф, конкурентный анализ, чтобы оценивать через призму конкретно нашего продукта.
Затем проходит в три шага. Когнитивный обход основного флоу, проверка по 10 эвристикам и классификация проблем по серьезности.
С введением на этом можно заканчивать. Я уже запустил работу этой директивы, просто чтобы под запись не ждать.
Прошло, наверное, минуты 3 или 5. Он нам наш аудит подготовил. Давай с ним ознакомимся.
Открываем, как обычно, в превью режиме, чтобы это все выглядело у нас красиво.
Итак, давай разберем отчет по частям.
Первая часть у нас когнитивный обход. На каждом шаге у нас 4 оценки.
Тут у нас все разбито на цель, обнаружимость, действие, связь, обратная связь и проблему.
Проблемы разного уровня на самом деле. Какие-то из них можно назвать надуманными, какие-то нет.
Какие-то из них важные, какие-то нет. Но в целом мы будем распределять проблемы по их степени важности.
Далее у нас эвристическая оценка, где у нас каждый из эвристик соблюдается, где нарушается.
После вообще все найденные проблемы в табличке.
Какая проблема, какой эвристике она соответствует, уровень важности этой проблемы и на каком экране она отражена.
Также рекомендация по тому, как эту проблему можно решить.
Вот, например, нет прогресс-бара, пользователь не знает, сколько шагов осталось.
Да, это действительно противоречит эвристике.
И вот, например, при конфигурации сервера действительно ты выбираешь первое, второе, третье.
У тебя навбар вообще пропадает, он не стики.
У тебя нет состояния прогресса, ты не понимаешь, сколько еще осталось.
Это эвристикам противоречит.
Это, конечно, нужно исправлять.
Если бы мы хотели вообще с минимальными запарами эту проблему решить, просто добавили бы сюда такой же фиолетовый прогресс-бар, который бы двигался слева направо по ходу вот этой конфигурации сервера.
Также у нас тут есть много всяких терминов и к ним нет пояснений.
Тут он, конечно, тоже говорит о том, что нужно добавить тултипы с кратким объяснением рядом с каждым техническим термином.
Вот, например, там есть IPv4, IPv6.
Ну, у меня нет понимания, а в чем вообще между ними разница, предположим, да.
И, ну, конечно, пользователю, если мы уже ему предлагаем всем этим заниматься, то, наверное, хотелось бы, чтобы у него была возможность с этим разобраться.
Но, опять же, тут как бы спорный момент.
Если сюда человек залез, то, наверное, он уже знает, что ему нужно, какие ему нужны параметры.
И, в целом, необходимости в этом нет.
Ну, so-so, тут нужно уже проводить тестирование и понимать вообще, какая аудитория до сюда доходит.
Также далее у нас сводка, какие у нас проблемы критические, какие серьезные.
Далее общая оценка с сильными и слабыми сторонами.
И топ-5 рекомендаций для конкретно нашего продукта.
Какие ошибки из TimeWeb мы можем учесть и какие фичи перенять уже в свой продукт.
Вот, например, здесь у нас прогресс бар, тот же самый, да, и стики навигации.
Тут нужна одностраничная форма, как в TimeWeb, то есть мы просто сверху вниз скролим без переходов по шагам.
Визор. Это стоит перенять, это удобно.
Но чего нужно избежать, как раз-таки вот этого длинного скролла без ориентиров.
Можно добавить якорную навигацию по секциям.
Можно здесь навигацию закрепить, добавить прогресс бар и переходить к конкретным параметрам, конкретным настройкам.
Если еще следовать эвристики видимости системы, то как раз в это закрепленное меню еще можно добавлять,
ну, какие-то галочки напротив тех пунктов, где мы все данные проставили.
Например, хотим мы посмотреть безопасность, перешли к ней, она там пятая, уже ближе к концу.
Что-то там проставили, у нас отмечено зеленым, к этому можно не возвращаться.
Это все, конечно, тоже очень полезно.
Итак, в качестве домашнего задания вам нужно провести аудит на ваш выбор, либо ближайший конкурент, либо ваш собственный продукт.
Если у вас он есть, замечательно.
Подготовьте скриншоты основного флоу, то есть 8-12 экранов, пронумеруйте их, по возможности добавьте юзерфлоу MD.
Ну, понятно, что, возможно, не хочется это все расписывать, но, конечно, так результаты будут более релевантными.
После чего запускаем директиву из материалов к уроку и получаем аудит.
Когда отчет будет готов, посмотрите на таблицу проблем.
Сколько у вас катастрофических проблем, сколько серьезных.
Есть ли, возможно, паттерн общий, то есть несколько проблем, связанных одной эвристикой.
Это значит, что у конкурента или у вас системная слабость в этой области.
Формат сдачи у нас скрин таблицы проблем и ваш вывод.
Какую системную слабость вы нашли?
Если таких нет, тоже замечательно, но вывод какой-то нужно написать.
На этом блок исследования у нас закончен.
У вас уже должен быть бриф, конкурентный анализ, аудит.
Три документа, которые дают полную картину.
В следующем уроке начинаем блок тестирования гипотез.
Будем создавать синтетические персоны на основе того, что собрали.
Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания и встретимся уже в следующем блоке.